>> HE DOES.
THE ART OF THE DEAL.
HE BOUGHT A COUPLE AIRFRAMES
THAT WELL ALREADY IN EXISTENCE.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT COMING
UNDER NEW SCRUTINY OVER IT
SURVEILLANCE OF THE TERM
CAMPAIGN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE TELLS US
ABOUT AN ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INTERNAL WATCHDOG KNEE-DEEP IN
THE INVESTIGATION OF THE CLINTON
EMAIL CASE WILL TAKE ON
SURVEILLANCE ABUSE.
>> IT WILL BE INVESTIGATED.
>> TAKING QUESTIONS AT A NEWS
CONFERENCE ON THE OPIOID CRISIS,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS PRESSED
ON THE MEMOS AND WHETHER LAWS
WERE BROKEN WHEN A SURVEILLANCE
WARRANT WHICH GRANTED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AIDE CARTER PAGE.
WILL YOU INVESTIGATE?
>> WE BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MUST ADHERE TO THE HIGH
STANDARDS IN THE FISA COURT.
I THINK THAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
THING.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL TAKE
THAT AS ONE OF THE MATTERS.
>> AFTER RESCHEDULING,
WHITE HOUSE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR HOPE HICKS TESTIFIED.
>> >> REPUBLICAN SOURCE SAID HC
>> >> REPUBLICAN SOURCE SAID HS
ANSWERED QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CAMPAIGN BUT NOT ABOUT HER TIMEI
CAMPAIGN BUT NOT ABOUT HER TIMEN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOT CLEAR WHETHER SHE INVOKED
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO COMMENT ON
THE INDIVIDUAL'S INTERACTIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
WE ARE COOPERATING.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID
REPEATEDLY THERE IS NO
COLLUSION.
>> ALSO ON CAPITOL HILL,
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY AGENCY PRESSED BY
SENATE DEMOCRATS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
THWARTING ROUGH RUSSIA'S FUTURE
INTERFERENCE.
>> YOU SAID PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
NEVER ORDERED A CYBER COMP TO
DEFEND OR THWART RUSSIAN
ATTEMPTS TO MEDDLE IN THE
ELECTIONS?
STICK A NEVER GIVEN SPECIFIC
DIRECTION TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
STEPS OUTSIDE MY AUTHORITY.
I HAVE TAKEN STEPS INSIDE MY
AUTHORITY.
>> HE SAID PUNISHING THE
RUSSIANS COULD TAKE MANY FORMS
FROM DIPLOMACY TO SANCTIONS AND
CYBER CAPABILITIES.
>> THERE ARE TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
US AND I THINK IN FAIRNESS YOU
CAN'T SAY NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE.
MY POINT WOULD BE IT HASN'T BEEN
ENOUGH.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE DISAGREED.
>> WE ARE TAKING A NUMBER OF
STEPS TO PREVENT IT AND LOOKING
AT A VARIETY OF OTHER WAYS WE
CAN CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT OVER
THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS.
>> SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS MOVED TO
DISMISS THE BANK AND TAX FRAUD
CHARGES IN VIRGINIA AGAINST RICK
GATES.
THE FILING IS TIED TO THE
AGREEMENT FRIDAY TO PLEAD BILL T